arts graduates across the developed
world often complain bitterly about the
difficulties they face finding good
employment they spend long and costly
years studying such subjects as history
art philosophy poetry and drama then
they reach the jobs market and discover
that no one has any use for their
distinctive skills and interests if
they're extremely lucky they may find
some kind of job but it will almost
certainly have no connection with what
they studied or pay very much
a great number end up making coffee
while deeply resenting against the
backdrop of frothing milk and roasting
beans how their years studying Foucault
or Spinoza seem to have gone absolutely
nowhere it's tempting to dismiss such
moans if someone wants to spend their
time finding out about post-colonial
theory reading South American novels or
deconstructing vampire films then that's
very nice as a hobby but it's harder to
see why anyone should expect to get paid
for doing so you don't get paid for
going to the cinema or attending parties
either but in truth the extraordinary
rate of unemployment or miss employment
of graduates in the humanities is a sign
of something grievously wrong with
modern societies it's evidence that we
have no real clue what culture and art
are really for and what problems they
could solve we like to declare the
humanities worthy and Noble and fund a
few professors to dig away in the
archives but basically at a societal
level we don't know what the humanities
could do for us and therefore how people
trained in them should spend their days
other than in preparing frappuccinos
good news is that the humanities
actually do have a point to them they
are a storehouse of vitally important
knowledge about how to lead our lives
novels teaches about relationships works
of art reframe our perspectives drama
provide us with cathartic experiences
philosophy teaches us to think political
science to plan and histories a catalog
of case studies into any number of
personal and political scenarios the
humanities have some of the biggest
clues out there
about how to fix stuff we're very bad at
a range of things that these arts
graduates could help us with we still
don't know how to make relationships
work this could be a trillion dollar
business we don't know how to
communicate what we're feeling to others
in a way they'll understand
we've added interpreting our emotions
and making good choices we don't know
how to treat others to get the best out
of them we don't know how to reform
advertising the media politics schools
architecture and a lot of the time we're
simply anxious and sad we aren't
creatures who need only practical things
like food and drink cement and running
shoes we also need help with a bits of
us that religion used a call our souls
and we matches as well call our psyches
this psyche related work deserves to
become a huge and legitimate part of the
world economy worth as much of the
cement trade or the lumber business that
there are so many arts graduates waiting
tables isn't a sign that they've been
lazy and self-indulgent it's that we
haven't collectively woken up to what
culture could really do for us and how
useful and totally practical it could be
you
you